I got an idea okay tell me this is
important yeah for those of you out
there who know something
contact
David at valuetainment and blow the
whistle this is your single opportunity
that best opportunity that I've ever
heard because he will Air it Patrick
valutaman.com
patrickman.com if you're a true
whistleblower and you were one of the
people that you worked there okay if
you're saying that person exists I want
to talk to you
I want to talk to you if you worked on
them you got proof all of that let's
talk about it because for me here's what
I asked yesterday
so we're doing a podcast prep meeting
and I asked a question I said how
important is it for us to know this what
do you mean how important is it as an
American to know listen what the hell
happened with 911 I'm asking an
open-ended question from everybody in
the room you know what everybody said we
have to know what happened we're
Americans we owe the truth yeah you know
we deserve the truth okay I agree so you
know I can more and more and more you
get deeper into this the more and more
you say okay this is pretty dark on what
happened here however why haven't many
whistleblowers come out why you know we
lead the world in whistleblowers America
it's like a thing to be a whistleblower
come out oh you're a whistleblower as
long as the right political side is
going to defend you so the only reason
why somebody wouldn't come out on this
is why I can't think of any it goes back
to motive and why
I can't think of any you know red
Sparrow you're familiar with red Sparrow
right okay what's red Sparrow Russian uh
uh uh uh you know beautiful women who
would go and it was their you know
secret intelligence or they would work
and get powerful men to flip how do you
flip men
historically it's the easiest way to
flip men how do you get information out
of men it's very simple okay you got
women compromise them and threat them
you got threaten them about some
information about them they can release
and do something to the people they love
the most it's that simple this is why a
lot of times if you really want to
recruit somebody that's going to be an
agent or we hear in the movies you
recruit somebody that's got no kids no
nothing this is why people who go front
lines that maybe work high high high
level jobs Delta things like that they
would like you to be single with no kids
and preferably not a lot of people you
love makes it a lot easier because
you're a little colder you know you're
less easier to be compromised
I'm not convinced all those 50 people
that worked or you know dozens of people
that worked on that were not
uncompromisable I don't know about that
again purely odds speculation and then
how much how much would it take to buy
you how much would it take to buy your
conscious a million dollars 10 million
dollars because for me and Patrick is
dead on here dead on there's the human
element and then there's the technical
element you are all about the technical
element respect
the human element is telling me this
don't add up because there's the before
and there's the after hey how would you
like to make a million dollars dude sign
me up I'm struggling what can I do
okay great we're gonna need you to do
this all of you can act in unison you're
gonna put the explosives all right this
building not building all right great
we're gonna do this all right cool then
this happens this image of this happens
I'm sorry I don't care how cold-hearted
and alone you are when you see the
people that die their people that are
jumping off the buildings that America
is under attack that like your conscious
is going to eat at you no amount of
money is gonna make it easy for you to
go to sleep at night we'd hear stories
of people committing suicide just
basically not wanting to live anymore
because they sold themselves for a
million dollars that to me is the part
that's like
I don't get it I know that you're kind
of dismissing the human element and
you're more focusing on the technical
element to me that is the the biggest
story here is how would you possibly
keep a secret and live with yourself if
you were one of those churches just so
you know just just so I make myself very
clear I I don't at all want to get to a
point where people think I'm 100 either
I'm not
I'm not all I'm doing is speculating
well that is all I'm doing and I'm
totally cool with someone saying I'm not
100 and he's 100 a jury that's my
problem okay but a jury does not
speculate they look at evidence and our
60 exhibits of the evidence has been
given to the U.S attorney in in
Manhattan to be given to a special grand
jury and the lawyers committee for 9 11
inquiry has has done this work and we're
making a film 9 11 crime scene to
courtroom to be introduced as a
supplement and that film along with
those 60
exhibits of evidence uh are evidence now
put yourself in the place of the grand
jurors who were asked by the uh
Prosecuting uh attorney to to evaluate
and an issue indictments if you can if
you can based on what speculation or
evidence they're going to do it based on
evidence they're going to appreciate
your speculation they're going to have
some of their own but it's the evidence
which we should be spending in the last
half hour talking about not speculation
that's what's on the table here that's
what's going to convince a grand jury to
indict people at top levels of
government who planned and executed in
an industry who planned and executed the
murder of three thousand people we've
got to get to the bottom not just three
thousand but 2 million in Afghanistan
and Iraq this started a 6.5 trillion
dollar global war on terror we've got to
get to the bottom of it our civil
liberties have been stripped with the
Patriot Act the military commissions act
the National Defense authorization Act
of 2012. we can be arrested without a
right to a lawyer a trial a jury we can
be assassinated we can that's legal now
tortured so uh there's lots of reasons
compelling us to look deeper at this
evidence instead of trying to dismiss it
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]